يعتبر من اهم رياضات التراثيه هنا في
محافظه شمال سيناء فهو مرتبط بالموروث
الثقافي لدى العرب منذ قديم الازل
[موسيقى]
ت الطالب
وبمناسبه الاحتفال بذكرى تحرير سيناء
وايضا العيد القومي لمحافظه شمال سيناء
اقيم هنا في العريش سباق للهجن في فعاليه
كبيره بمشاركه عدد كبير من الفنانين
والمسؤولين بعد القضاء على الارهاب في
المنطقه فيما اعتبرها الحاضرون اشاره الى
عوده الحياه الى طبيعتها في هذه البقعه
الساحره الحدث اقيم بالتعاون بين مجلس
القبائل والعائلات والحكومه المصريه سباق
الهجن هي بالنسبه لنا التراث وبالنسبه لنا
اهم رياضه لان احنا ما عندناش يعتبر الكره
القدم والحاجات لان دي بالنسبه لنا اهم
رياضه ودي ترمز الجمل ده يرمز للصحراء
ويرمز للصبر
وقبائل سيناء او قبائل بصفه عامه تحب
السباق الهجن والهجن بالاخص لانه هو اللي
علم ابن سينا الصبر على العيشه في الصحراء
شارك في السباق الابل التي وصلت اعمارها
الى ثلاث سنوات من الاناث او الذكور اليوم
في هذا
مشارك تنوعت الاشواط من اشواط الحقايق
للجايا للجذع الثنائيه
وزول من كل محافظات مصر المشتركين
وقبائل مصر تنافسوا في السباق خمسه عشره
قبيله من مختلف مدن شمال سيناء كما تمت
زياده قيمه الجوائز واضافه تقنيه الفار في
التحكيم على غرار مباريات كره القدم طبعا
يعني دي رساله لاهل العريش ان الدنيا تمام
والامن رجع والامان
وبنقول للناس اللي جايه من بره يا مرحبا
بكم في اي وقت يعني خلاص البلد فتحت
وعايزين الناس تيجي والرجل تيجي والسياحه
تفتح اصلا سباق دي عاده اساسا عند البدو
في شمال سيناء يعني يعتبر الرياضه
الاساسيه في شمال سيناء
دي ان هي ترجع تاني في حد ذاته ان شاء
الله لمردود على شمال سيناء يعني ايه ان
شاء الله حاجه محترمه باذن الله
الحدث كان له اثر كبير على اهالي سيناء
بعد سنوات من شعورهم بالعزله سمر بشات
لصباح العربيه من العريش بمحافظه شمال
سيناء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات